hello and welcome to the session that
shows you how to increase agility and
reduce costs with bmw as a service
or as i'd like to say what's this new
hot vmware on google cloud thing that
everyone's talking about
hi i'm manoj and i lead the google cloud
vmware engine product team
and i'm co-presenting with psy who will
join us later after my section of the
talk is over
so we learned today how google cloud
vmware engine finally makes it super
easy for you to go from your vmware
deployments on-prem to google cloud
we'll also learn what the service is all
about as well as some key advantages and
use cases
and then we'll show you how to get
started with the service
uh with some cool demos along the way
so what's the problem statement
so let's face it on-prem infrastructure
can be a challenge
it constrains id staff because they have
to do laborious tasks related to
infrastructure procurement and
maintenance and be reactive to business
needs with long lead times
but it also means that they're using
legacy systems that are not adding value
to the business
other than keeping the lights on
and therefore they can't scale with ease
they're locked into what they have on
premises and are forced to pay
uh you know to to pay for over
provisioning
uh and
forced to provision for
peak usage
so how do we solve this problem
google cloud has created a service
called vmware engine which solves the
problem and it really gives you a fast
forward button to your journey to the
cloud
it's the fastest way to migrate your
apps from vmware to the cloud you get
the platform you know and love with all
the familiar interfaces in the vmware
platform such as vcenter
and the service is sold on the basis of
hyper converged nodes which includes the
service the
software license the storage compute
networking and all infrastructure you
need to run vmware natively on google
cloud
the solution is sold by google and is
supported directly by google
but it has been built with the
cooperation of vmware and vmware fully
certifies this offering
and you can consume vmware basically in
a fully automated self-service manner
just like you consume any other cloud
service
and by getting all the service needs
from one company you simplify the way
you consume vmware in the cloud i want
to highlight that we have a really
strong partnership with vmware to make
google cloud vmware engine happen
and the partnership is not just at the
technology and engineering level
our collaboration extends far beyond
that
to ensure that our customers have a
smooth experience with the service
to find out more i encourage you to
check out the sessions and the customer
conversations at vmware's marquee event
that just happened
vmworld 2021
you can also check out the blog post the
link is indicated on the slide
and a lot of the vmworld infrastructure
i want to note is
actually you know the user labs
and a lot of the hands-on experience for
customers at vmworld 2021 in fact was
hosted
on google cloud vmware engine
so we are very happy and proud about
that
so what we did
to find out whether the service adds
value we surveyed a lot of it and
application leader owners
and
uh and we found that the service
delivers
we found that the service is really able
to meet the goals of the cloud
transformation journey that we talked
about
first
we find that
the customers are able to
provision vmware quickly and in minutes
in google cloud and get to the time to
value to be really low
you can run next to a wide variety of
data ai and infrastructure services in
google cloud that google cloud is
known and loved for
you get extremely reliable high
performance highly redundant
infrastructure
to ensure that you have a no compromises
enterprise experience is super important
and the best part is that you'll be able
to save money while you're doing all of
this by leveraging the cloud economies
of scale and
you know the pay as you go flexibility
that you get in the cloud
so when we were designing this service
we had a certain mission and a vision in
mind
and that was really what we call
cloud native vmware
and cloud native vmware means three very
specific things
first it means
that it's a cloud optimized vmware
experience
meaning that
customers can consume vmware as simply
as any other cloud service and take
advantage of the elasticity
of scale that i talked about
and the scale on demand model
and you can do so much faster
than any other way
in
in getting your bmi infrastructure to
the cloud
we simplify the use of bms services
through unified identities access
control and support and a customer
cataphore
has moved to a self-service and scale on
demand model on their vmware consumption
with the service and have done so much
faster than was ever possible before for
them in the cloud
the second part of what cloud native
vmware means is a cloud integrated
vmware experience and
what this means is you can transform
business applications
with simplified integrations
of google cloud services like cloud
operations bigquery and amp hours and so
you can respond to business needs more
quickly in a more agile fashion with
these services
a large telco provider has
streamlined their operations management
monitoring and logging coming from both
vmware as well as the rest of our
convention into a single pane of glass
with the cloud operations integrations
we have with vmware
and third
part of the cloud native vmware is the
familiar third-party applications
that you can
that you consume on-prem
uh as well as in the cloud
what that means is you can extend your
ecosystem of third-party apps and
services that are critical to your
business
for your various needs or such as
desktop and backup and dr
and we've partnered with
solution providers and third-party
application developers such as veeam
rubric and cohesity
and
we've also partnered to solve the
storage infrastructure problem with
netapp
to provide storage solutions for vmware
so that's how we bring this
mission to life with these three
elements of cloud optimized cloud
integrated
and ecosystem enabled
so one of the surprising aspects of
adopting a
vmware engine is that customers in fact
save quite a bit compared to both
running on-premises and choosing other
options in the cloud
and you must have seen these kinds of
studies many times that they show that
they save through over a three-year
window but then you find that the cost
of initial adoption is high
and
that's not the case with our service
let me level with you if you're going to
the cloud anyway and you're coming from
vmware there's no better place than
google cloud vmware engine because the
platform is the same as what you consume
on-prem
and with the
over subscription capabilities of the
vmware platform you get very high
density and lower cost per vm
and what better way to understand this
value than to hear a testimonial
directly from the customer
so let's take a look at a video that
gives you a good idea of how mitel
is getting the best of both worlds
running the vmware platform they know
and love on google cloud
mitel is a modern communications company
leveraging state-of-the-art technology
with offices throughout the world our
challenge is really netted out to the 4s
stability sla security and scale google
cloud vmware engine is really solving
the stability and the reliability
platform issue with that we're able to
move out of about 15 data centers which
gets us closer to our data center
decommissioned objective the benefit
going forward in the google cloud is now
we can look at different deployment
options as we grow
[Music]
what a great video
and let me give you just a little more
perspective i was in fact involved in
the mighty experience and they moved
thousands of vms most of which happened
on just a couple of weeks
and they're running a telephony
application with voice and video needs
and they read and they needed low
latency and really high throughput
and with the vmware engines fully
allocated networking fully dedicated
networking they were able to get
sustained performance and not have to
worry about
you know multi-tenancy or any other
customer stepping on their toes and and
then they so that's how they truly got
to this best of both worlds experience
and you know got from the vmware
environment that they truly love to
google cloud that they have come to now
know and love as well and with that i'll
hand the bit on to my colleague sai
who will walk us through the
differentiation in the use cases and
give you more examples of the goodness
coming from the service
and how you can truly supercharge your
journey to the cloud so over to you sci
thank you manoj i'm sai and i'm a
product manager with google cloud let's
get right into it
with google cloud vmware engine you're
able to migrate to google cloud without
changes to your applications
you use the same tools and processes in
your staff can hit the ground running
from an experienced standpoint there is
a single vendor google which means that
for your purchasing support and service
needs google is there for you
further given that this is a google
managed service you do not have to
manage the lifecycle of your vmware
infrastructure google does that for you
so you can focus on your apps with our
differentiated networking you can truly
leverage some of the native capabilities
that allow your apps and environments to
be global with unified management
unified access control and access to the
same third party pooling that you have
built and invested in day two ops
becomes simple you can run both vms and
containers in google cloud vmware engine
and this is extremely useful for high
performance applications where locality
and running on dedicated infrastructure
is important
further high bandwidth low latency
private access to co-located google
services reduces the amount of work
required to modernize applications
let us look at some of the key use cases
of google cloud vm manager customers
that want to migrate their entire data
centers to the cloud due to events such
as data center exits mergers
acquisitions or those that just want to
extend their data center to add capacity
in the cloud
can invest in google cloud vmware engine
it is completely consistent with the
on-premises environment we simplify the
networking and provide the service
globally
this also applies to customers
who are looking to support
high-performance applications
in isolated compute environments and
also apps and voices that are
incompatible with other infrastructure
platforms
for those that are looking to develop a
cloud-based dr strategy due to events
such as upcoming audits protecting
against ransomware protecting tier 2
tier 3 apps or geographic risk
diversification can also look towards
google cloud vmware engine given our low
cost dr solutions and support for a wide
ecosystem of tools
for customers looking to support
distributed desktop infrastructures in
multiple geographies or those that have
upcoming software licensing renewals or
that are looking to address seasonality
or support with more end users at scale
say for their work from anywhere
initiatives our service offers support
for both industry-leading vdi solutions
with vmware horizon as well as citrix
finally for those customers who are
looking to unlock the value of google
services for the applications and
infrastructure
google cloud vmware engine offers a path
towards where you can move your
applications rapidly to the cloud and
then
modernize over time
we are now available in 12 regions
worldwide with the latest edition of
mumbai
while we have four nines of sla in a
single zone in each of these locations
in other cloud context this might not be
possible
there are customers who want even more
availability and for them we have
additional zones coming up please speak
to your google cloud sales
representative or your customer engineer
if you have requirements for a
particular region that is not shown over
here
google cloud vmware engine is hipaa
compliant and other key industry
certifications are being worked on these
include iso pci dss and soc
now google cloud vmware engine truly
delivers a global highly performant
enterprise friendly flexible networking
experience
with simplified regional and global
routing modes you have one global
network with no necessity to create
regional network designs and connect
them this greatly simplifies and reduces
the cost and complexity to have more
than one point of presence in the cloud
you can architect and connect different
parts of your environment easily across
projects and across regions with
capabilities such as multi-vpc and
multi-region networking
with a fully redundant 100 gbps
east-west networking with no
over-subscription
as well as a superior low latent packet
rate performance our architecture really
helps customers who have applications
that are latency sensitive or have high
performance networking requirements such
as voice over ip applications and other
end user workloads as you've heard from
our customer testimonial
finally with google cloud vmware engine
your current networking vendor solutions
can be brought to the cloud we offer
flexible public ingress and aggressive
options with support for three different
ways for workloads to get access to the
internet via the google cloud vmware
engine edge the google cloud edge or
your own corporate dmz we also have
built-in integration with cloud dns and
you can also bring your own corporate
dns
we are an enterprise ready platform that
scales and supports for your work
enterprise workloads with up to 64 node
private clouds running on highly
performant and scalable google cloud
infrastructure dynamic resource
management with auto scaling enabled
we also provide a fully dedicated single
tenant high performance node with all
nvme storage and with rich gcp
networking and full functionality of
nsxt with access to nsxd manager
with 99.99 sla in a single zone with 5
to 32 nodes in a cluster you have the
high availability that is required by
some of your mission critical
applications
in addition we also support rich vdi
environments with large-scale vmware
horizon architecture supported as well
as the ability to extend and migrate
vmware-based citrix vda workloads is
fully validated by citrix
one of the questions we often get is can
i bring my vmware just my vmware
environment or everything i consume on
it how can i make my vmware environment
and consumption better in the cloud the
answer is we offer a fully compatible
vmware experience so you can bring your
existing tools and processes as is
whether it is your vmware tools or your
third-party tools that support vmware as
well as our own marketplace services in
addition you can take advantage of
google cloud services whether it is
optimizing the embedded protection using
cloud storage a zero footprint dr
solution with active fuel building
hybrid high performance and availability
architectures for your databases
modernizing your applications using
containers and kubernetes centralizing
and modernizing your operations
management or enriching your apps with
data analytics and more in the next
segment we will look at a couple of
these examples
now as you consume vmware in the cloud
you want to ensure that you avoid
switching between screens for operations
management for example if you have a
performance problem you want to be able
to troubleshoot all aspects of the
application dependencies in one place
rather than go to different systems to
solve part of the problem
while the vmware engine service fully
supports existing vmware monitoring and
logging tools without changes as you
start to develop more hybrid
applications that partially live outside
of the vmware engine environment getting
all operations data in one place will be
important to solve this you can use
google cloud's operations service
formerly stackdriver you collect metrics
logs and traces across vmware engine and
other google cloud services you can use
built-in out-of-the-box dashboards and
views to monitor platform
as well as the applications and query
and analyze these signals as well
you can see the information from the
vmware infrastructure as well as the vm
guests and application as soon as the
vmware infrastructure goes you can see
the vcenter the side do log analysis
this does not require any agent
installation metrics such as vm cpu disk
and network usage are all available
for vm guests and applications you can
use open source agents to collect
additional logs and metrics so if you
want to troubleshoot any application or
gain insight into the optimization or
usage you can do it all in one place
as with the second example we will look
at a demo of how we integrate bigquery
with workloads running in google cloud
vmware engine to unlock the value of
data analytics for our customers
the fraudulent charges data set is in a
mysql database running on-premises in a
vm we have taken that data and migrated
the vm to google cloud vmware engine
using hcx
now we can access the data with google
cloud services
to move the data into google cloud we
replicate the data into a cloud sql
instance using the google database
migration service
we can then write a simple sql script to
show the zip codes with the most amount
of credit card fraud
as you can see google bigquery
transforms that data to appear as a
visual map let's take a deeper look into
the data from a global view first
now we would like to see on a zip code
basis which part of the united states
shows the highest incident of credit
card fraud here you can see that this
zip code has an unusually higher
incident of credit card fraud
now how do you get started now moving to
the cloud can bring up concerns about
how to rationalize existing license
investments that you may have made on
premises
now we are introducing this program
called the catalyst program which
provides google cloud vmware engine
users financial flexibility to
accelerate their
journey to google cloud eligible
customers can now get one-time google
cloud credits that offset unused vmware
licensing investments
you can apply these credits against the
consumption of google cloud game engine
as well as any other google cloud
service of your choice the following
year
this is a consumption based program and
this program is available directly
through google cloud or through existing
google cloud channel partners that you
work with terms and conditions applied
so if you are interested please do
contact your google cloud sales
representative or your partner service
manager for more details
in addition with the planned capability
of a single or private cloud you can
experience this service with a single
node for non-production quick proof of
concepts
note that the single node private cloud
will remain live for 30 days after which
it will expire or reset
during this period you could upgrade the
full production cluster with all your
data as well
so what are you waiting for as next
steps there are a few resources that you
can take advantage of google cloud
vmware engine comes in a hyper converged
form factor with all compute and storage
included with the node however there are
cases when you need additional storage
for capacity hungry scenarios such as
large-scale databases media electronic
design automation data warehousing or
large-scale analytics
you also need to
lower cost and dr scenarios so you can
protect your mission critical data
without overhead
to solve for such needs we are now
announcing today's support for netapp
cloud volumes in preview if you think
that this is going to be useful for you
i encourage you to contact your google
representative to find out how you can
participate in the preview
contact your google team for a google
cloud vmware engine demo you can also
conduct a free assessment
with google cloud or with our partners
as well as schedule a half day workshop
with your google cloud
team to go over the results of that
assessment this brings us to the end of
this presentation
thank you so much for watching